I were to say that there was any weight
on body count I would say you'd have to
consider that the circumstances that
that body count happened in right where
that person was at why they were
sleeping around right and what space
they'd might be in right so guys okay
they changed their habits guys I don't
think that's true I don't believe that's
true I think that is actually kind of
making too much of a generalization I
know you work on the job
but that is too much it's it's a lot
more nuanced than that I don't think as
many men as you think actually I'm just
saying if a woman came to me and said
I've slept with a thousand men because I
was broken and I had been abused and
blah blah blah right you still slept
with a thousand men where's the
compassion in that though where's
where's that's what I'm not thinking
about I'm thinking about you've had a
thousand penises inside you're going to
be with someone shouldn't compassion be
a main factor in that relationship right
an understanding of who they are of what
they've been through shouldn't that be
amazing Factor the world but the world
yeah the world doesn't owe you
understanding like that's entitlement
you're not you're not entitled to
someone's compassion and understanding